SUBJECT: I think on day
hikes, it's really easy just
to go out and sort of be
wowed by how big the world is
and how beautiful it is.
But when you're on a trail
that is like the PCT,
it's over 2,000
miles, and you're
doing this day after day,
everything sort of gets
boiled down to the most
simple parts of your life.
You wake up and
you eat breakfast.
You get dressed and you
take down your tent.
And you walk.
In your mind, it's truly just
-- it's slowing things down.
It's steady and it's constant.
And it really, truly is
a very active meditation.
INTERVIEWER: You
decided you wanted
to take on the Pacific
Crest Trail, or the PCT.
What is that?
SUBJECT: The Pacific
Crest Trail is
one of the three biggest
national scenic trails
in the United States.
It's a footpath that goes
from Mexico to Canada.
It passes through the Mojave
Desert, the southern Sierras,
the high deserts of
Northern California,
the Cascades in
Oregon and Washington.
I've been in this sort of space
of deciding whether or not
outdoor education
is a career that I
want to devote the
rest of my life to.
And about a year
and a half ago, I
said, heck, I want to know
if I can actually do this,
and if I can do it on my own.
INTERVIEWER: How did
your parents react?
Were they supportive?
SUBJECT: They were
so supportive.
I remember the first
time I called my mom
and I said, so, I think
I'm going to hike the PCT.
And she was like,
of course you are.
Like why would you
do anything else?
INTERVIEWER: What did that feel
like when you first set off,
and you're on the trail?
SUBJECT: I was scared.
I was really nervous.
You sort of-- you get
out into the desert,
and like the first
couple of nights
you sort of realize
like, oh my gosh.
I'm hiking the PCT.
But I was never alone, you know?
You're only alone as much as
you want to be on the trail.
There's so many people.
So many good people out there.
And so I kind of teamed
up with a little group,
and we traveled together
for most of the desert.
And we were able to kind
of go through it together.
INTERVIEWER: While
you were on the trail,
a very traumatic
situation happened.
Can you tell me what happened?
SUBJECT: Yes.
When I hiked out over Kearsarge
pass with my hiking partner
and a friend of
mine, I was greeted
by all of my uncles, and their
partners, and my brother,
and our family dog.
And I was told that
my parents had just
been killed in a car accident.
Obviously, that rocked my world.
That just changed everything
I thought I knew about myself
and about what I
was doing there.
After I found out, I
sort of just walked off
and found a little river.
I remember not being able
to feel any of the water,
and there was snow everywhere.
It must have been cold, but
I couldn't feel anything.
And I remember starting to say
out loud I have to keep going.
I have to keep going.
And it just sort of became
like a chant, almost.
And I was whispering it, and
then I was saying it louder.
INTERVIEWER: So you
decided to keep going.
SUBJECT: I did.
Yeah.
I did like dig deep,
and say, you know what?
I'm not going to let this
define myself or my experience,
and I'm going to
be stronger for it.
You know, I know my parents
wouldn't want me to turn around
for the world.
INTERVIEWER: How did the
trail become a form of therapy
for you?
SUBJECT: I would wake
up in the morning,
and there were some
days where you just
feel like you've lost all
desire to do anything, really.
The last thing you
want to do is get out
of your warm sleeping bag and
hike 20 miles, but you do it.
And once you're doing it, just
emotion-- it's everywhere.
It's high.
It's low.
It's just like-- it felt like
it was just yanking me around,
this reality of this.
My parents are just been killed.
Like, what do you do
with that information?
The trail just guides you
into this pace of walking,
and just-- it's the
right speed to travel,
and it's the right
speed to heal,
because you're not--
you can't run from this.
You also can't sit still.
So by walking, you're moving.
You're moving forward,
you're moving through it.
But you're not running from it.
We're all different.
We all heal differently,
and this is what
I need to do to begin to heal.
INTERVIEWER: How do you
think your parents would feel
about this journey that
you've taken on and conquered
on the Pacific Crest Trail?
SUBJECT: I don't think they
would have expected anything
less, honestly.
The trail became
something different.
It no longer became something
that I was doing just for me.
And I think they'd be
tremendously proud.
INTERVIEWER: Now
meet Louis Bird,
an inexperienced
rower who decided
to cross the Pacific Ocean.
Click here to find out why
he took up this challenge.